today we're talking about gcloud storage
open source and Innovation and contact
center AI I'm Debbie and welcome to this
week in Cloud where we serve you the
lowest latency news
cloud storage customers often ask us
about the fastest way to ingest and
retrieve data from their buckets getting
the best performance often requires the
users to know the right flags and
parameters to optimize transfer speeds
in many situations customers are using
cloud storage with other Google cloud
services and are looking for one tool
that can be used to manage all their
Google Cloud assets
that's why we're excited to announce
gcloud storage the latest addition to
the Google Cloud CLI for up to 94 faster
data transfers learn more on the blog
at Google we believe anyone should be
able to quickly and easily turn their
artificial intelligence idea into
reality open source software has become
increasingly important to this goal
heavily influencing the pace of
innovation in Ai and machine learning
ecosystems we're committed to open
ecosystems in order to make AI
explainable ethical and Equitable
enabling anyone to innovate explore some
of Google's most significant OSS Ai and
ml contributions from recent years as
well as how that commitment to open
Technologies can help organizations
innovate faster and more flexibly all on
the blog
with increasing demands on contact
centers Enterprises are investing in AI
driven Solutions so they can continue
providing value to their users Google
Cloud build contact center AI ccai for
short to streamline and shorten this
time to value and ccai platform our
newest addition takes a crucial step in
this effort by introducing end-to-end
call center capabilities
after debuting these new capabilities in
March we're excited to announce that
ccai platform is now generally available
across the U.S Canada the UK Germany
France Italy and Spain with more markets
soon to come
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud